give them all of our enthusiasm in our
applause 22 all right good afternoon so
we are p2p learning tree and we want to
improve student achievement through
greater student ownership and connection
students are thought of as passive
instead of active learners our school
system I know I've been sitting in a
latching class and a teacher who have no
connection with is almost preaching me
information in half it's going past me
research tells us and reveals that of
all the different ways that we can have
teaching and learning in classrooms and
in school systems discussion groups
practice by doing and teaching others
the immediate use of knowledge are the
three best ways to improve retention and
deepen learning to do that we're going
to have to actually think about the
learning environment and the thinking
that we're doing in our learning so what
if we challenge the assumption that
teacher students have to learn from
expert teachers so now imagine a
different kind of school where students
learn by teaching other students so what
would that look like I mean you guys
many of you are teachers in this room
and so what what kind of student
learning would be there if students have
to stand in your shoes so the process
here imagine a head teacher teaching
safe about for students and each of them
are not only taught the content but also
how to teach they go off they prepare
their lesson plan you can feedback from
their teacher and they go off and teach
their peers and the process continues on
and how do we manage quality in this
whole system so we're trying to build a
platform around this to provide content
as you can see we're trying to provide
feedback mechanisms analytics to find
out what students know aware and our
program considers all the stakeholders
because we don't essentially change
anything we still have a certified
teacher who's teaching to all the
current standards and assessing the
students and the same with the budget
there's very little change in that so
this summer will test out the p2p model
in a summer camp evaluate and refine it
and then try it again
um in a after school program and then
after that we can expand it and
implement it on a larger scale how do
you select the students in the top of
the pyramid how do you select the first
fall over there so we're looking at the
analytics that we're collecting about
students what their interest level is
what their past experiences are what
they've really enjoyed and learning
before and have gone deeper in it and
these students will rotate depending on
the content right so in we're learning
about marine biology this is a high
school class there may be for students
that really surface the ones that have
the interest and the background
knowledge and the teacher moves them
forward and another content area if
we're doing literature it might be
another for students so everybody gets a
chance to be an expert and our starting
group would be selected by themselves in
a summer program so that they've put
themselves forward for it wouldn't you
actually aren't you creating levels of
categories like first grade student
second and so on because the last ones
actually are going to get the knowledge
on different filters they'll shift
sometimes it's on you sometimes you're
the leader sometimes you don't know you
have to shape to anyway and this
wouldn't necessarily be going down in
terms of grade level this might be the
same ninth and tenth grade classroom
that is learning different topics and
then it would be a third-grade girls who
do this and it would be all third
graders learning different topics and
the quality of the teaching may not be
worse on the bottom areas we're not
saying the best students are necessarily
at the top because it'd be based on
interest in other mechanisms so but now
you come confuse me you said those which
rise up would come in the first layer so
they sound interest and other other
things so they're not necessarily the
best students are the smartest students
ok so don't so um I'd urge you just to
look at some of the things that have
been done on trying to keep the status
distinctions among students in balance
while you're trying some of these things
for the data collection piece is really
key so teachers know who's already
taught three lessons or three content
areas who hasn't